claro el primer billón de dólares irá
para remodelar la infraestructura
tradicional de eeuu es decir se
construirán en cerca de o se remodelarán
cerca de 10.000 puentes y 20.000 millas
en las carreteras de eeuu en este primer
billón de inversión también están
incluidos pues vías férreas puertos y
remodelación de aeropuertos 100 mil
dólares irán para renovar tuberías para
asegurar agua y agua potable a los
estadounidenses de menos recursos y
otros 100 mil dólares 100.000 millones
de dólares perdón para pues a entrenar a
las personas para poder pues responder a
este ambicioso plan de infraestructura
el otro billón y es donde está la
polémica es también para los proyectos
de cambio climático de economía verde y
ahí es donde los republicanos pueden
poner problemas para su aprobación en el
congreso cristóbal de donde van a venir
esos recursos esos 2 billones de dólares
porque hemos visto que eeuu ha hecho
unos grandes gastos recientemente para
activar la economía por la pandemia del
sí y bailén dijo que está este proyecto
se financiará con sobre todo un alza en
impuestos una vez en impuestos
corporativos del 21 por ciento al 28 por
ciento
los republicanos obviamente pues no
están de acuerdo con este alza pero pues
hay que recordar que en la reforma
tributaria de trompa hace unos años este
impuesto este impuesto corporativo
estaba en un 35 por ciento y pues él lo
bajó a un 21 por ciento hay que
mencionar también que en las próximas
semanas bailén va a anunciar otro plan
cercano a los 2 billones de dólares más
es decir en total un gasto en las
próximas semanas que anunciará el
presidente yo vaivén de 4 billones de
dólares este segundo paquete de
proyectos va destinado a las familias
estadounidenses y entonces fuese será
eso 4 billones de dólares que anuncia el
presidente yo bailé en gasto público